unterhalten
es handelt sich um eine
literaturverfilmung uns warum die
verfilmung des buchs gleißendes glück
selber titel von at kennedy aus dem jahr
ich glaube dass kein zufall dass bisher
noch kein buch von erkenne die verfüllt
worden ist weil sie eine derartig
intensive sprache hat und eine so
ungewöhnliche art und weise zu schreiben
hat dass einem die bücher eigentlich vor
augen stehen ohne dass man von anderen
menschen produzierte publizierte bilder
nun dazu bräuchte es geht um eine
eigentlich eine ganz einfache geschichte
wenn man sie unterbricht nur auf die
struktur nämlich eine frau trifft einen
mann die frau habe insofern eine
besondere frau ist ja keine große frage
ins leben nämlich die frage wo es mein
gott geblieben
du weißt was habe ich nicht mehr die
kirche gehe das weiß ich dass du recht
weil du vernunft angenommen hast bist du
es nur noch nicht wahrhaben weiß doch
noch durch herumgesprochen bis das wärs
mit einem schuss wartet diese frau hört
nun im radio eine geschichte von einem
so einen selbsthilfe guru und dieser
mann erzählt also davon wie gedanken die
wirklichkeit beeinflussen können
aber sie wartet mit mir auf den nächsten
vorbeifahrenden zug und lässt mich auf
die waggons hören ihnen zu hören und sie
sagen alle meinen namen
egal ob entwicklung diese beiden sehr
unwahrscheinlichen figuren treffen sich
auf einer tagung weil die frau mit ihrer
frage eigentlich zu diesem buchwert und
da wäre die entdeckung macht bzw
das nicht sie entdeckte sondern er
erzählt es ihr als er mal sturzbetrunken
ist das eher eine auch ein ein riesiges
problem hat er ist nämlich zwangs
masturbiert ich sie nun alles nicht sooo
themen die meine im deutschen film
unbedingt vermuten würde
und ich muss sagen dass mir eine ein
etwas radikalere zugriff auf dieses in
sich hochbrisante und sehr radikale und
sehr radikal erzählte material auch
lieber gewesen wäre also eine etwas und
entschieden inszenierungs art das finde
ich sehr schade andererseits machen
diese beiden darsteller wirklich das
meiste aus dem was sie was der regisseur
ihnen erlaubt sie ist ungewöhnlich genug
der sich sagen würden sollte man
hingehen und co
und vor allen dingen sich eben diese
beiden wirklich grandiosen schauspielern
kommen die sätze sagen die man auch
nicht von jedem deutschen schauspieler
höheren leichte zum beispiel sagt
martina gedeck wie geht es mit dem
wechsel als einerseits ganz gut ist
einerseits natürlich auch die komik aus
dieser szene nimmt
ich bin auch neugierig neugierig
soll ich anfangen wie oft ich am tag und
an ihre im durchschnitt sechs mal
häufiger die skandalöse brutalität die
skandalöse einmütig gomez wird
eigentlich bleibt es so auch zu
unbestimmt wenn ich was findet dann
lasse ich sofort alles stehen und liegen
das sieht dann so aus dass ich nachts
wenn ich eigentlich ausweiten
korrigieren will da sitzen und einen
deutschen schäferhund zu sehen wiederum
bekommt er von einer mass effect und das
ist so ein bisschen für mich das problem
mit diesem film der serie macht das
einerseits aber dann auch wieder nicht
richtig und oder nicht sieht es nicht
wirklich durch würdest du denn hier
wirst mich mehr
mir würde es schon ganz genügen dass es
mit ihr ist gut wer sich entscheidet den
film zu sehen sollte das vielleicht
alleine tun ich glaube sein film ähnlich
wie das buch der gesellschaft nicht so
gut verträgt